-There are so many things I have
to congratulate you on,
and I on -- I don't know
where to start.
I guess we start with the Oscar
nomination and the win.
-Thank you.
-"The Power of the Dog."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, thank you very much.
You kind of feel that you're
winning when you get
offered a role like that,
for a director like that,
that's a double win and then for
her to win Best Director
for us, we were dancing around
that Oscar.
-What was she like to
work with?
-She's just a trip,
she's so much fun.
She's just very unassuming.
I only knew her for her work,
before I met her.
I'd never met her socially.
I had no idea what was going to
walk through the door.
She just came in with a little
rucksack,
"Oh, hi, Ben, how are you?"
Your family is great.
Chatty, everyday, talking about
the weather.
-Did it feel like it
was going to be a big movie or
did if feel like it was kind of
going to be an independent
even though it was
a giant budget?
-I was focused on him, and Phil
Burbank and working with her.
I didn't really think how it
would play out as a movie.
It wasn't really my head space
at all.
-And you were so great and so
creepy almost, I want to say.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know how to describe it.
-I get very defensive
about that character,
but I'll still take that
as a compliment.
-Yes, yes, yes, yes!
I just know you.
And we've done so many bits
on the show.
You come and you've played
played charades.
This was not you.
This was acting 701 right here.
This is like advanced acting
class right here.
I just loved it. Congratulations
on that. That was awesome.
-Thank you very much.
-And I got to see that.
Oh, my gosh, I'm so happy, I
can't wait to congratulate
you next time I see Benedict.
And then
"Spiderman: No Way Home"
goes on to be, like, the biggest
film of all time
makes, like,
a gazillion dollars.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's so much fun.
-Great fun.
-I mean, what was that?
Did you know that was --
-Yeah, I did.
[ Laughter ]
-That one you knew.
-Well, look, it's a testament
to John Watts and the three,
you know, Jacob Z, and Tom,
they've got this beautiful
John Hughes homage mixed in with
the ultimate universal love,
there is for that, that kid,
that hero, for Spiderman,
and Peter Parker.
And it was such a good script.
Such a good concept. And then
there was that "little secret."
-But it was so much fun to
watch!
-It was so much fun.
And what I think they did so
blindingly well
was just a mix humor with pathos
to mix surprise with elation
and expectation and confound
expectation.
They just, they managed to pull
off a huge feat.
Which, apart from anything else
because of throwing in Toby
and Andrew,
it meant you were celebrating
like 20 years worth of film
making on top of all that.
It was a real punch.
-It was a moment.
I thought it was great. And then
we'll talk about Dr. Strange --
but also you're hosting
"Saturday Night Live" again
which I'm so happy to hear.
-So excited.
-The building is buzzing that
you're in the building.
And Arcade Fire.
-One of my all-time favorite,
favorite bands.
I heard him last time,
he was incredible.
These guys I've been following
since they first began.
I feel like --
-Anything different
you're going to do the second
time around?
-Yep, breathe and enjoy it more.
It goes so quickly. You kind of
watch the tape the next day.
Going, "Was it any good?"
You have no idea.
You're at the call at 11:30
at night.
Even for stage work, that's when
you're coming off the stage
for who you meet up with
and have a drink or something to
eat before going home.
That's just when you're going to
work on "Saturday Night Live."
It's so weird.
-It's one of the rare live
television,
I don't know if they
do live any more.
-Nothing like it, that's why I
wanted to do it again.
-Once you do it, the
book, the chapter is over.
The book is closed and you go--
but you were fantastic.
So, break a leg.
I know they're all writing,
they all psyched
that you're here.
Congratulations on that.
-Very excited, too.
-Let's talk about
"Dr. Strange."
With Marvel movies on our show,
normally we're not allowed to
talk about anything.
Has it changed, has it changed.
Are we allowed to talk about
anything?
-No, I'm basically here to
talk about a movie
I can't talk about.
-Yeah, perfect.
-So how do we talk about a movie
that we can't talk about?
-Well.
-It's coming out.
-I mean maybe.
-Can we say that? on Friday.
-You, yeah that's true. That is
actually what's happening.
-It will be out
and revealed to the world.
-And then, you know --
-It will be projected.
-There's some people in it.
Some people in the film.
-Humans?
-Mainly, yeah.
-Yeah? Mainly humans
are in the film.
And, uh, Imax?
-Yes, that is apparently
somewhere it will be exhibited.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. Sounds great.
-2-D and 3-D.
-Oh, and 3-D?
-It'll have sound. And music.
[ Laughter ]
-There's rumors that there might
be a cameo or two in there.
-Okay, well, look, I guess I am
on the Fallon show, so maybe,
maybe, Jimmy, I can just, just
one clue as to somebody
who may be in the film because
it's coming out quite soon.
I'm not going to say their name.
-Okay.
-But, I'll see if you can guess
it from a theme tune.
Of something else that they've
done that's quite well-known.
Ready?
-Hmm. Okay.
-[ Hums theme song ]
-Okay, really?!
-No.
-Okay, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-That was pretty good,
by the way.
-Aren't you disappointed people
that bought their ticket
wanting to see two Tom Cruises
films in one month.
[ Laughter ]
-Tom Cruise's not right?
-Yeah, yeah, it's very good.
-In these films you do
your fight scenes --
-Yes.
-With very like, you
have the sorcerer-type moves.
-Gestures.
-I'm sure you've been trained to
do these.
-Endlessly.
-Yeah?
-It's hard work. Yeah.
-That wasn't my question.
-Oh, what was your question?
Sorry? "Is it hard work?"
-Is it hard work?
-It is.
-No, but I mean I always thought
maybe you could teach me
a move or two maybe tonight if
you could show me how --
-I think the best way to do
this, probably,
because this is, like
the sixth time I've played him.
So I, you know, you get some
perks after awhile.
And one of them is that I don't
do the hand moves any more.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-In this film Sam Raimi does
them, so what you need to do
is you need to be me, right?
I need you to stand up.
And just sort of put your hands
behind your back a little bit
so that people think these brown
arms are yours.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, Jimmy, it's just an
excuse for us to hug really.
-I don't want this to
end, yeah. I really don't.
Oh, my goodness. Well, hey,
let's go into this portal
over there and then we can go --
you know, I'm a little thirsty.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much.
Just a little thirsty.
Now, I want to tell you all more
about Dr. Strange,
but I really can't.
I'd rather just --
I can't tell but
I can show you a clip.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
here is Benedict Cumberbatch
in "Dr. Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness!"
Take a look!
♪♪
[ Screaming ]
-Whoa!
♪♪
-[ Monster roars ]
-[ Yells ]
Oh, no!
-[ Grunts ]
♪♪
[ Grunting ]
-Look out!
[ Whirs ]
-[ Grunts ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't wait! This weekend!
Benedict Cumberbatch, everybody!
"Dr. Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness!"
Opens in theaters and IMAX
this Friday.
And he hosts
"Saturday Night Live"
with musical guest Arcane Fire,
this weekend!